So today, we're going
on from zero dimensions
to one dimensions, and we're
talking about line defects
in order to understand
what they mean.
We're going to
contextualize it in terms
of stress/strain curve.
So we'll talk about that.
And all of this is
called the dislocation.
So that's our goal for today.
Now, on Monday, after
lecture actually,
a student came up to me and
asked a really good question.
And it was related to
the Hume-Rothery rule.
Remember, on Monday, we
talked about point defects,
zero dimensional.
So you have a
localized disturbance
in the lattice-- of vacancy.
You take it out.
You can have that occur in
a material that's ionic.
Not a metal, but maybe
an ionic material.
And then you got to think about
charge neutrality, Schottky
and Frenkel.
And then we talked about
substitutional defects, which
would be where you take
an atom out of the lattice
and you put another one in.
And Hume-Rothery, I
mentioned, had come up
with some empirical observations
and so I listed these.
So he studied a class
of metals and came up
with these general guidelines.
And as with so many things
that we've learned so far,
these are general rules
that get broken sometimes.
So the question the student
asked was a very good one.
Said, well, if the
valence of something
you're trying to substitute
into something else
has to be the same or higher,
how does p-doping work?
How does a p-type
semiconductor work?
That's a really good
question, right?
Because the valence is
lower, by definition,
that's how you make it p-type.
A-ha.
So my response was, well,
because Hume-Rothery
was designed around metal,
I'm not sure how much of these
apply to semiconductors.
Although for semiconductors,
you do want to make sure
the sizes are similar,
at the very least.
But that got me thinking.
And so I went and I read
some papers last night.
Here's one on the
valence effects
and relative stabilities--
valency effects.
So this is from
the '80s and I just
wanted to cite something here.
So here they say almost
a half century ago--
so that's Hume-Rothery, so
it's the '80s or the '30s--
pioneered the study of
the effect of valency
on metal alloy phase equilibria.
They found that a lower
valence metal, like silver,
had only a very small solubility
in a higher valence element,
like antimony, but that the
solubility of the reverse
was large.
So that's where
that rule came from.
And here's the next part of
this paper I want to share.
"Although the relative
valency works well
for that select
group of alloys, it
does not apply to the
periodic table as a whole."
So this other guy looked
at 607 different systems
and found that 22% of the
time, the vacancy rule
works, and 27% of the
time, it violated the rule.
And honestly, I'm not
sure we can call it a rule
anymore if more times
than not, it's violated.
This is a new thing for me.
So that is just to say
that this rule probably
is really conditional on
the specific elements you're
talking about.
I think the much more important
ones are these three here.
The valency rule certainly
depends on the system.
And all of the Hume-Rothery
observations were empirical--
it's important to keep in mind.
General guidelines meant
to be broken more than half
the time, apparently.
[CHUCKLES]
So where were we?
But thank you for that question.
It was a great question.
It gave me some great reading
last night-- materials.
Zero dimensional, Monday.
One dimensional, today.
There we are.
So that's the focus.
Now, the story
today starts at MIT.
It starts at MIT in the 1940s.
Because there were
these two students--
there they are, Harold
Hindman and George Burr.
MIT students back then were
a little bit older, I guess.
So those guys, they
were in an MIT lab
and they were trying to
study how parachutes break.
How does a parachute break?
Because why is that
an important question?
Because you don't
want it to break.
Right?
And it's one of
these things where
you want it to never break.
Like, you really
want almost 100--
so they were studying
why it breaks.
So they were taking a
parachute and pulling it apart,
and there it broke.
Take another kind of
material, pull that apart.
It broke.
This one didn't,
but it's too heavy.
They were studying
the relationship
of the mechanical breaking to
the material of the parachute.
I love that logo there.
That's the two of
them in the lab
at MIT pulling on a parachute.
They just have a tug of
war with a parachute.
But the problem
was that there was
no instrument at the
time that could give them
the sensitivity to the force
that they were pulling.
There was no instrument that
could capture what they needed
to make a better parachute.
So being MIT students,
they built their own.
They built their
own and they added
a whole bunch of electronics
into this instrument.
And that is where
the name comes from.
It's an instrument that
had a lot of electronics
for the time.
Instron is the name
of their company.
Instron is now synonymous
with stress/strain curves.
So you go into any
university, any company,
you look at how-- if they
need to measure something,
like whether an egg breaks
or not at what force,
it's an Instron machine.
It's an Instron machine.
There it is-- same logo.
And because those
machines give you
the most accurate and
well-calibrated description
of the force that you're
applying on this material
and you can apply it
very, very slowly--
so these are very common
machines to look at the force
you apply, to take
it how much distance.
So we're going to
talk about that today.
Now, we're not going to talk
about it in terms of eggs.
We're going talk about
it in terms of a wire.
So there's a wire.
It's a little hard to see there.
There it is.
There's another
Instron machine--
this is a red one.
And here they are and
they're looking at this wire.
And this wire is some
material-- maybe it's copper,
maybe it's aluminum.
And they're saying, what
happens to this thing
as I just pull it
in small increments?
What is the force that
I have to put on this
to pull it a certain amount?
Now, that is an important
graph, and it's so important
that I really want you guys
to understand this graph.
Because it is the way
that mechanical properties
of materials are
first often analyzed
and it's a plot of
the stress, which
is equal to the force per
area versus the strain, which
is equal to the change
in the length divided
by the original length.
Now, what I mean by that?
Well, let's take a wire.
Here's the wire.
There's that wire in there.
OK.
So here's a wire.
And I'm going to apply
a force this way.
That's what the
Instron is doing.
So there's some force
being applied to it
and there's some
area of the wire
and there was some
original length.
OK.
This is called a
stress/strain curve.
It's the force
divided by the area
that you apply to get the thing
to stretch a certain amount.
Now, those MIT students
were also very smart.
They knew that many
materials, as you first
start stretching them, the
bonds between the atoms
are kind of elastic.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that if I stretch
it a little bit, it goes back.
Might stretch it a little
bit more-- it goes back.
They're like springs.
So when you think
about the deformation
of that wire and
many other materials,
you've got this elastic regime.
And that means that it's
reversible, as I just said.
Reversible.
And the displacement-- so
it's reversible displacement.
If I stretch it, it goes back.
Reversible displacement
only occurring
under some applied force.
Applied force.
This is an elastic stretch.
If I've stretched this
material elastically
and I let it go and it goes
back, it's like a spring.
Hooke's law is going to apply.
So Hooke's law applies.
So F equals kx or minus kx.
You can press it or--
OK.
Hooke's law.
So that means that if
I start pulling on this
and I start here--
so there's no stress
and there's no strain,
and if I start pulling
on this, then I'm
going to get a straight
line, like that.
So that's going to be
the elastic regime.
But these MIT students--
the thing is, they
knew something else.
They knew that for
a lot of materials,
it didn't keep going like this.
It didn't keep going linearly in
this nice, elastic spring way.
They knew that either the
thing broke completely
or it deformed--
or it started deforming.
And that is called
the plastic regime.
We're coming to plastics later.
And this is a
permanent shape change.
Permanent shape change.
And you can imagine,
if I'm going
to permanently change
the shape of a material,
it's got to be ductile.
So if it's something
that's going to break--
remember, we talked about
ionic versus metallic.
The sea of electrons allows
those metals to be ductile.
And that has to do
with the bonding
with the electronic structure.
If you want a material to
be able to change shape
permanently and
not crack, you need
that ability to be ductile.
So there's a plastic regime.
And that makes this
change dramatically.
So what happens now is,
if I keep stretching it
beyond this elastic regime,
the stress/strain curve
is no longer linear.
And in fact, it might
look something like this
until, at some point-- so this
would be the plastic part where
it's literally deforming,
it's changing its shape.
And then finally,
I've stretched it
to the point where it fractures.
So that's called
the fracture point--
you just can't pull it anymore.
You just can't pull it anymore.
And they're studying
parachutes, but they
knew that there were a lot
of surprises out there,
there's a lot of
complexity in this.
And they needed to understand
this regime and this regime
in order to really engineer the
parachute to make it better.
They had to get that data
and there were no instruments
that could move it and
measure it and calibrate it
carefully enough.
By the way, this plastic
deformation that happens--
this permanent shape change,
but without breaking, that
happens very early on.
So there were people
working, for example,
with aluminum, saying,
well, given the bond
strength of aluminum, I predict
a certain mechanical strength
that aluminum could go to.
And then they find that it
starts deforming 100 times
lower than that.
100 times lower.
Why?
Because it enters into
this plastic regime.
It doesn't stay elastic.
So what I want to talk
about today is how--
I hope I've convinced you
how important this is,
and I'll have a why this
matters on that as well.
But what I want to
talk about today
is how these one dimensional
defects fit in with this.
How these one dimensional
defects fit in.
And in fact, they
explain it all.
They explain it all.
This is what the
wire looks like.
When you stretch a wire and
you look at it carefully,
it's not just a
little bit longer.
It has these very set
features that occur.
It's not just deforming
in any random way.
It's deforming in a
very specific way.
And so what I want to
talk about is that way.
The plastic deformation
mechanism is called slip.
The mechanism is
called slip that
leads to plastic deformation.
And it leads to that picture
and it leads to the data
that they got from
the Instron machine.
So where does it come from?
This is a 2D picture
of a lattice.
So you can imagine what
I've done-- oh, I'm
going to hand this out.
I love this.
I can just sit
and look at this--
this is so cool.
So this is a cubic--
you can think about it as
a simple cubic lattice.
Here's a plane, here's another
plane, there's another one.
Look at that yellow one there.
So many planes.
I got lost there just
thinking about it.
I'm going to the other side.
You could get lost, too.
That's one of the planes.
Imagine it.
Now, you notice here, I've got
hanging out-- because why not?
Oh, why not?
Because there's no
other possibility.
Because vacancies always
exist, as we learned Monday.
They cannot not exist.
So there is one right there.
Cool.
There's an interstitial
point defect,
there's a substitutional
point defect.
That's all from Monday.
They're just hanging out.
But here's what we're
talking about now.
Look at this.
I want to take this
little symbol--
this T, and I want to
look at the lines that
come down from it.
So there they are.
So these are now planes.
These are planes.
These are
crystallographic planes.
And now, look at
the other side of it
and notice those same
planes are following--
see to the left there?
You see how that's
now a plane, a plane?
So this is actually lined
up from the outside in.
It's lined up, it's lined up.
Ah!
Right here, I put
an extra one in.
You see that?
That's an extra plane that
doesn't go all the way through.
If it went all the way through,
it wouldn't be an extra plane.
So it's sandwiched in here.
And then here, it
continues over there.
That one kind of goes like that,
and that one goes like that,
and then they go back
to the normal planes.
I have inserted a half-- if
you want to think about it--
of a plane into--
right there.
Look at that.
That is called a dislocation.
That is a one
dimensional defect.
It's a dislocation
that is caused
by putting an extra plane
that stopped somewhere,
and where it stops, you draw
a little T in the crystal.
Oh, let's go with the mean.
Come on.
There we go.
We'll go back to this.
So that is called a dislocation.
That is called a dislocation.
That is the 1D defect.
It's called a dislocation.
It's a line defect formed
by what is essentially
a misregistry of atoms that
gives you an extra plane.
Now, you can already see that
if I put a line defect in there,
it's messing with the
bonds at this place here.
Here, the bonds just go
along, they go along.
And then all of a sudden, I've
got a misregistry now because
of that dislocation--
because of that dislocation.
One way to look at
it is with the model.
Another way is just
get ears of corn.
I did this last night.
I actually-- I got ears of corn.
That's really true.
And I looked inside.
This isn't from there.
This is from the internet.
But there it is.
The corn needed to grow
another row and so--
it's not going to
grow a half kernel.
Well, actually, it could.
It does sometimes.
But here, it grew another
full row of kernels.
And there it is.
There's a dislocation.
It's very similar to
what we're looking at.
Now, there are two
types of dislocations.
This one, where you insert
an extra plane in this way
is called an edge dislocation.
There's another
type of dislocation
that we won't talk about in
this class called the screw
dislocation.
You can look it up.
It's a different
type of line defect.
But the one that
we're concerned with
is called an edge
dislocation and it's
described exactly in this way.
And the way you note
it in an atomic scale
drawing like this--
by putting that upside
down T where the edge is.
An edge dislocation.
Edge dislocations in corn.
Now, you can actually
see these things.
And on these models,
the dislocations
look very nice and uniform and
you can hold it and look at it.
But in reality, here's an
actual video of dislocations.
These are groups
of dislocations.
Notice, these are
1D line defects.
They're places where you've
got this extra plane.
Notice, that they're
all over the place.
They're not just straight,
they bend around in the crystal
and they move.
And the movement is critical.
The movement is critical.
That's what's going to get us
back to this, the movement.
This is the defect, and then the
movement is what gets us this.
So let's take a look.
So here's an here's an example.
This is a piece of material
that under the microscope
is being pulled.
Watch what happens.
Well, those things are moving.
They're forming, they're
ending, they're reforming,
they're interacting
with each other.
That one didn't, but whatever.
And they're spreading
out, they're growing.
Those dislocations
and their movement
is why this doesn't crack.
It's why this can
move, this can bend.
It's why this point
is 100 times lower
than you might have thought.
And that can be understood
by thinking about the bonds.
That can be understood by
thinking about the bonds.
Here's a sequence of pictures.
So this is the dislocation.
You see it there.
Now, what I'm doing
is, I'm pushing--
or let's not push yet.
We'll do that on the next slide.
For now, I'm just
watching it move.
Here you see it moving.
There it is.
How does it move?
Well, here's a model.
There is a dislocation and you
can see that if I take this
bonding area around here and
I connect this atom to there
and then you start pushing--
there's a strain field around
there--
and then you push it
over, you might be
able to move it over to there.
And maybe you could
keep on doing that
and keep on moving it
over and over until it
gets all the way to that end--
all the way to the
end of the material.
Here is a super
polished, high detail
animation of that process.
Here it is.
I'm starting over here
and watch the dislocation.
There it is.
There it is!
And it's moving and it's moving,
and those bonds are breaking.
Let's watch that again.
Here it is.
There, it formed.
But why did it form?
Because, you see, what happened
is, I took this material
and I applied a force to it.
I went back to the wire and I
did this or maybe I did this.
And the material
said, OK, hold on, how
can I respond to this thing?
Well, either I can
respond elastically
and all my bonds
could stretch, but I'm
getting to this
uncomfortable place here.
Or a dislocation could
come in and allow
me to translate a whole
set of bonds over by one.
So I'm applying a
force to this material.
You can think about it as a
force maybe on the bottom g--
here, let's watch what happens.
Look at this.
I've got a little
extra room here.
Now watch what happens.
There it is, there it is.
And I have moved
the whole top row
of atoms over-- the whole
top three rows over by one.
So I have transformed
this so that the force--
if you think about it,
the force on the bottom
could be applied that way and
the force on the top that way.
The atoms get to a
certain point where it's
like, no, my elasticnesss--
I'm not sure I
want to go anymore.
But a dislocation comes
in and saves the day
and it allows that to happen.
Because here's the alternative.
if I want that same translation
to happen, that same slip,
I would have had to break
all the bonds at once.
If I didn't have a dislocation,
this is what would-- ah,
there's the dislocation.
One bond at a time,
one bond at a time.
Or the much, much
harder ask, especially
since there's 10 to the
20 something of these,
is to break them all at once.
There it is.
Bam.
That's why that doesn't happen.
It just takes too much energy.
But if I can just call up a
dislocation to the rescue,
I can translate an
entire set of atoms
with much, much,
much less energy.
Did you see that?
So the dislocation
moving is what
allows plastic
deformation, it's what
allows these atoms to
slide over one another.
It is what enables
this region to be there
and it's what defines it.
A very important point here--
aw, you got a goody bag.
That's OK.
Was he in the class?
It doesn't matter.
We share.
[LAUGHTER]
If you guys have friends--
just came in and took one.
If you guys have friends
that need goody bags,
we are here to help.
I will never turn
down a goody bag.
There is a plane here that's
moving on another plane.
There is a plane that's
moving on another plane
and it's doing it only because
of this location, that one
dimensional defect.
Now, that is slipping, so
it's called a slip plane.
It's called a slip plane.
And it's the plane along
which the dislocation moves.
[PHONE RINGING]
OK.
We got a phone going on there.
Now, I want to make a
really important point here.
Because what the
dislocation is allowing,
what this defect is allowing
you to do is resolve forces.
That's what you're doing.
I'm putting this force on--
it's again, the Instron.
I'm pulling the wire and the
material is like, hold on,
I got to respond to this.
How can I do--
yeah?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yes.
And I will come back to that.
It's this plane.
Where's the model?
Who's got the model?
Is that the dislocation model?
It's the plane where
the dislocation
comes in and can move.
Why?
Because that's the
plane that is--
by motion of the
dislocation, that's
the plane that's slipping
along another one
by exactly this animation.
I'll talk about this
slip plane in a minute
also and more about it.
So what this motion,
what this slip plane,
what these movements of
the planes allow is is it
allows you to resolve
an applied force.
So I come at this material
with a force and I resolve it.
It's resolved at
the atomic level--
and I'll finish this-- at the
atomic level along that slip
plane.
That's what it does.
The Instron pulls or I pull on
the parachute, like the logo,
and then either the
material is going to break
or maybe it's just in
that elastic region
and then it will go all the way
back or it's going to deform.
And if it deforms,
what's it doing?
It's feeling the force and
it's trying to resolve it.
And it resolves it by
those dislocations moving.
The planes move on
top of each other.
Well, so let's go
back to this plane.
What plane is it?
If I look at the planes, which
are somewhere out there--
you can imagine that if
I've got all those planes
and they're looking at the
Instron and the force being
applied to me, which one is
going to do the slipping?
Well, you can imagine this
with a very simple analogy.
If I push on something--
if I push on a rope,
what does it do?
Well, it kind of
curls up, it doesn't
do too much-- it doesn't move.
But if I really want to
try to resolve force,
I got to move those atoms.
But if I push on a
stick and not a rope,
then the stick just all moves.
So the plane that is going
to move across another plane
is going to be the most dense--
the closest packed.
It's going to be
So the slip plane--
let's write it here.
Slip plane-- and I'll give
you an example in a minute.
Slip plane, closest packed
or highest planar density.
Because then I'm
pushing on the stick.
In the material, I've got stick
and ropes defined by the plane.
You can see it over there.
Some of those planes, they're
beautiful-- the yellow one,
but it doesn't have that
many atoms per area.
So if I try to
move that one, it's
not as strong of a plane to
move and to resolve my forces
at the atomic scale with.
So I'm always going to go
for that strongest plane.
So that's a slip plane.
Now, a great analogy
for this is the rug.
So if you're helping people
move or you're setting up
your own rug, and you
get it and you put down
the rug base like that,
and then you put it down,
and you're, ah!
I missed it by a foot.
I got it wrong.
This rug weighs--
rugs are really heavy.
You pick it up, you're
like, oh, I'll just move it.
You call a friend and you both
pick it up, and you're like,
this is 1,000 pounds.
Who knew?
It's really a pain.
And so then you think
about dislocations
and you think about
how a material would
handle this situation.
And you say, well, if I just
make a little dislocation,
like a little
crinkle there, and I
move that, think about
how much effort it
takes to move that instead.
Not much.
You make a little crinkle,
and then you move it,
and then you move it.
It doesn't take much
force to do that.
It takes a lot less than
picking up the whole rug.
That's the motion
of a dislocation.
We just talked about
the plane that it is,
but which direction?
Which way should you move it?
And so this is the second part.
So you have the slip
plane, the closest packed
or highest planar
density, and then
you also have the
slip direction.
The slip direction
is the other part.
Which way does it go?
I've got the closest
packed plane.
Which way should it go?
Well, for this, you can
see from the experiments,
and when you look at the wire--
again, if I take a copper wire
and I pull it and I
look at it with my eyes,
it just looks like the
uniform wire's been stretched.
But now I magnify it.
This is what you see.
So you can see that there
are very definite directions.
This is actually all
the same direction.
So that's a slip plane
and there's a direction
that it slides.
I think this can be understood--
I love this picture,
because I love ping pong.
These are ping pong
balls and you guys
can do these
experiments yourself.
You put a bunch of ping
pong balls in a row,
and then measure
the force that it
takes to slide it depending on
whether they're closely packed
or not.
This is a little
counterintuitive sometimes
when you first see it,
but it makes sense.
The more densely
packed the plane
is, the easier it is
for one set of atoms
to slide across the other.
The easier it is.
So you can feel it.
If I have to let this one--
and they showed it
just by angle at which
it would slide or roll.
I like the idea of two
people going in there--
and here, you'd have to apply
more force to make that one
slide than this one.
You can see it, again, with
this super precise animation.
There it is.
One of them and
there's the other one.
Look at how much more work you
got to do to get that thing
to go over and over.
No.
If you've got a high
density of atoms,
it's actually easier to slide.
It's easier to slide because
you've got more bonds.
And so I'm not having
to fully break a bond
before I get to the next one.
So the slip direction then is
going to be the highest density
direction, so it's
also the close-packed--
I've got an example there--
close-packed direction.
So notice, this would be like
a direction-- a vector and this
is a plane.
Well, that's jogging
some memories
of understanding crystals
by their Miller planes
and directions.
We say, well, what would
this be for, say, FCC?
There's an FCC crystal and
there's an FCC lattice.
So if I had, say,
FCC as an example--
well, OK, so let's see
if I can really quickly--
oh, boy, here we go.
There it is.
And here are the face atoms.
There we go.
OK.
That's the outer part of
FCC-- three of the faces.
And now, OK, but if
I take a 100 plane--
so let's take the 100 plane.
Then I've got that.
And you'll remember, I've got
these atoms on the corner.
Why did I draw that
so much bigger?
Let's not do that.
That would be like
the 100 plane.
And this one might be the usual
lattice constant A. You could
also look at the 110 plane.
Here it is.
The 110 plane.
That would look
like this and this.
That would be the 110 This is
just bringing back memories--
I know good ones.
Here is the 111 plane.
So here, we've got this
one, this one, and this one.
In an FCC metal or
crystal, which plane
is going to slip and
along which direction?
You can get that now.
Because you can calculate
the planar densities.
In which case is the
packing of atoms-- in which
of these planes
is it the highest?
Well, you've got to know
the number of atoms.
So how many atoms are in this?
2.
How many atoms are in this?
Oh, why?
1/4, 1/4-- I'm just counting
in the unit cell of the plane.
So 1/4, 1/4, 1/4, 1/4--
1.
It only counts in the plane
if the plane goes right
through the atom.
So here in the 110 I've
got 1/4, 1/4, 1/4, 1/4.
OK.
That's 1, plus 1/2, 1/2.
Two.
I've got two atoms
in that plane--
effectively, two
atoms in that plane.
But what about here?
Oh, boy.
OK.
1/6, 1/6, 1/6.
You see it from the
geometry it's a triangle.
So that's 1/2 from those
corners, plus 1/2, 1/2, 1/2.
2.
I've got the same
number of atoms
in those planes of the unit
cell-- of those planes drawn
within these unit cell boxes.
But they're different
planar densities.
They're different
Because the area here is equal
to a squared in this case,
it's equal to root 2 a
squared in this case.
So it's larger.
Same atoms, larger area.
That's not going to have a
higher packing than that.
And now I get to have really
a lot of fun with triangles
and thinking about the height
here and stuff like that.
And the area of this
one is equal to root
3 over 2 a squared less than 1.
That's going to have the
highest planar density.
You know it.
That's going to have the
highest planar density.
So that's a connection now.
So you can connect
now what we've
learned about
Miller planes, about
crystallography to this simple
calculations of density,
to this incredibly important
behavior of materials--
plastic deformation.
Because now you know how that's
going to plastically deform.
It's going to deform along
its closest packed plane.
And you can also look
at the directions.
And it's shown here
that the slip direction
will be along one of those--
that's the highest density
direction, the 110.
So it's going to slip along
one of those directions.
Good.
Slip plane plus this
together combined--
these are called slip systems.
The slip plane
and the direction.
That's called the slip system.
OK.
Now, there's another
thing that happens
with this location that's
so cool and so important
to materials and to the things
we want to do with materials.
It has to do with the
fact that, like I said,
the dislocations come
in and they can be
a total mess and entanglement.
By the way, how did it
come in the first place?
If I started with
a perfect crystal,
where did it come from?
How could there
be a dislocation?
It can come in from the edge.
You've got an edge there.
There can be a mismatch
and I call it up--
I need a dislocation
or I'm going to break.
Boom.
Comes in from the edge,
comes in from the edge.
They come to the rescue.
This is a simulation
of exactly that done
by the chair of the Department
of Civil Engineering, Marcus
Beuhler--
a simulation he
did some years ago.
But he's modeling
the dislocations--
that's what you're
going to see here--
as a piece of metal is cracked.
Watch this.
Watch them come in.
It's saying, I
need you, help me.
And there they go.
Now, look at what
happen-- there's
so many of them forming and
forming, and now tangling
and tangling and tangling.
Then he's going to zoom in.
It's very cool.
Those are dislocations like
we saw in the experiments,
but this is a computer
simulation of them.
They're still kind of tangling.
Here they go.
They come in, they get called
in to relieve the atomic force
and let the material slip.
But there's something
that happens now.
There's something that happens.
Because now we go
back to the rug--
we go back to the rug.
And look at what's happened.
I'm going along and I
did the calculations
and I had no one to
lift it, it's too heavy.
But I'm going to create a little
dislocation and move it along.
And I come across someone
else's dislocation here.
Look at this.
I'm trying to roll mine and
there's another one there.
What's going to happen?
I can't go anymore.
I'm blocked.
So when dislocations
tangle up, you
can imagine now it prevents
dislocations from moving.
But dislocations moving is what
gives me the plastic regime.
So as I introduce
dislocations, I
make it so that it's harder
for dislocations to move.
There's actually
a name for that.
There's a name for that
because it really changes
the mechanical properties.
It's called cold hardening
or work hardening or strain
hardening-- sorry, cold work.
Cold working.
So work hardening or
sometimes strain hardening.
Why is it called hardening?
Because you're literally
making this material harder.
What's happened is, I've
taken away ductility,
so I've made it more brittle.
I've taken away the
plastic deformation.
It can't do as much
plastic deformation,
because that only happens
by motion of dislocations
and I'm locking them in.
But I'm letting it maybe go
a little further in how much
it can elastically deform.
Maybe now, once it
gets to here, it says,
you know what, I've got all
these dislocations in there,
It's not letting me
plastically deform,
so I'll keep
elastically deforming.
But that gets you up to
much higher stresses.
It gets you up to
much higher stresses
with elastic deformation.
And so this is a plot--
look at that.
That's called the-- oh, I
should have put that down there.
Let me label that because
it's a pretty important point.
I labeled the fracture point.
This is the yield point.
There it is, the yield strength.
That's called the yield
because it's where it
yields to plastic deformation.
So here you go.
You've got some steel,
you've got some brass,
and you've got some copper.
This is plotting-- look at that.
This is the percent cold work.
Cold work is work hardening.
Work hardening is adding
dislocations on purpose--
on purpose.
So that what?
So that I increase
the yield strength
so that this material
can elastically
deform now up to higher and
higher and higher strengths.
But the ductility goes down.
When you bend a
paperclip, don't you
go and tell anybody it's
because of heat that it breaks.
That's not why a
paperclip breaks.
It gets hot-- or warm.
You bend it back
and forth, it breaks
because you are putting
dislocations into it
and you're making
it more brittle.
In fact, if you
heated it up, you
would anneal those out and
make it more ductile again.
That's how you get rid of
the dislocations-- you've
got to heat it back up.
It makes it brittle,
the ductility goes down.
Why does this matter?
Well, this is one reason.
If you don't plan your
cold work carefully,
you might make the
material too brittle.
You wanted it to be
so hard because this
was such an important ship and
it was going to be a big deal
and the launch was
really exciting.
And then it cracks in
half, the entire ship.
Why?
Because you didn't look
up what dislocations mean.
You didn't take
3.091, that's why.
That's a pretty big crack.
The main why this matters--
oh, I couldn't help it.
I am a big fan of wind.
Wind energy is
growing and growing
and it's such a great
national resource.
Here's the global capacity.
This is install capacity
for wind turbines.
But see, this is a
mechanical materials problem
that you are now equipped
to think about more deeply.
Because, you see, you can do
a lot of different experiments
on those turbines.
So the blades here are critical.
You can imagine that you
want them to be light,
but if they're too light,
they may not be strong enough.
And then how do they
need to be strong?
Because you've got huge
amounts of wind coming at them.
And it turns out, you need
to hit just the right balance
of elastic deformation before it
goes into some plastic regime.
You need to hit just the
right balance of ductility.
So here's, for example--
these are some simulations.
Here are some experiments on a
new material for a wind turbine
blade.
And then you put it out there
and look at what happens-- ice.
By the way, this ice comes off
at hundreds of miles an hour
in chunks.
These farmers are
not happy about that.
Seriously.
And those are bugs.
Actually, bugs in wind turbine
blades is a serious problem.
How do you clean bugs off of it?
Because it dramatically
changes the aerodynamics
and the efficiency.
It also can damage
the blade itself.
So there's all sorts
of work going on.
How do you make bug-proof
wind turbine blades?
OK.
Well, now just spray
it with something.
Ah, but then does it have
the right plastic deform--
does it have the
right yield point
or is it just going to crack?
And by the way, it's got to
have 5 times 10 to the 9 cycles
before it can fail.
That's the metric.
So that's a pretty
big ask of a material.
It all comes down to
understanding this curve.
And in the broader sense
of materials, this to me
is a very exciting ask.
Why?
Because if you look at a plot
of the density of materials--
heavy, light.
Good.
Kilograms per meter cubed.
And the Young's modulus--
now, this is a measure of
the strength of the material.
It's a measure of
how much strain
you could put on the material
before it breaks or goes
through deformation.
But look at this.
Different materials are here--
rubbers, foams.
OK, foams have relatively
low Young's modulus,
but they're really light.
That could be good.
Up here you've got metals
and alloys, ceramics,
you've got polymers in here.
But notice, I've got so
many different applications
and needs in the
applications and I've
got this plot where I've got
nothing here and nothing here,
even though, if I could
fill this out and dial up
any stress/strain curve for
any density or Young's modulus,
you can make a big
difference in a lot
of different applications.
So I think this is
a great challenge.
Have a good night.
See you guys on Friday.